you will walk cold fusion baby
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
from an outside perspective it would
seem that in recent times Apple has been
stagnating a little bit but what's
actually happening Ken Siegel who worked
with Steve Jobs and came up with the ad
slogan think different had a great
analysis and makes an interesting point
Apple seems to have lost the focus of
functional simplicity from the design of
hardware and software to more complex
product lines and even company structure
simply put the Apple under Tim Cook
isn't the same as the Apple under Steve
Jobs Siegel stays that Steve Jobs cannot
be replaced and I agree whether you
loved him or hated him Steve had the
ability to make things happen by sheer
force of will it's the method that some
people would call dictatorial tactics
but nevertheless it meant tremendous
success for Apple so what's going on
with Apple right now and are they losing
their innovative edge are they
stagnating in this video we'll take a
look they'll be talking about a few
instances in this video but I think
there's one example that's a perfect
microcosm of Apple's problem the new
MacBook Pro as a disclaimer this is all
my opinion and I'm just stating the
facts and evidence to back it up let's
get into it
so with the 2016 MacBook Pro Apple has
taken out some very useful ports like
the SD card reader which is a disaster
for video editors in addition to this
the ports are Thunderbolt ports in USB
type-c format so while this is great for
the future right now this means to plug
in a harddrive a USB or even iPhone
you're going to need an adapter yes the
new MacBook Pro has a great design and
there have been improvement in
performance and display but removing
functional ports this kind of behavior
from Apple is almost like arrogance
through design and it's starting to
plague all of Apple's products the
products are getting thinner and lighter
at the expense of features that many
customers actually found useful Einstein
once said things should be as simple as
possible but no simpler and of course
he's right you can safely apply this
concept to industrial design a product
should be as functionally simplistic as
possible but once you make it simpler
than that threshold it actually becomes
more difficult to use in this case more
adapters and more dongles and this isn't
the first time remember the single USB
port in the MacBook last year that was
almost an insult to prospective
customers and there's no reason to talk
about the missing headphone jack in the
iPhone 7
taking one look at the way the Apple
Mouse charges is hard to believe that
this product was the result of a company
renowned for its industrial design is
strangely out of character and the same
goes for the iPad pro in the way the
Apple pencil charges again out of
character and not much more needs to be
said and yet again the same thing for
Apple's iPhone charging case battery
hump is huge and they could have just
flattened out the battery to cover more
area and make it thinner it almost seems
like they didn't think it through till
this day there's no touch on any of
Apple's MacBook lineup here's the
argument for why that is at Apple we
build prototypes around all sorts of
ideas so we certainly explored the topic
deeply many years ago and had had
working models but decided that it
really was a compromise that for a
device that you hold in your hand like a
phone or a tablet it's very natural rest
your hand on the tablet and work that
way we think touches at its best
grafting touch on something that
fundamentally was designed around a
precise pointer really compromises the
experience today you saw Craig federighi
state that a UI designed for a pointer
wouldn't work well would touch well
somehow Microsoft made that exact
concept work sometimes when I travel I
take with me a little Windows 10 touch
PC and touch works great with it
Microsoft's OS has now geared for both
touch and a mouse I don't see well with
enough careful thought Apple couldn't
pull off the same thing and this comes
at a time when Microsoft is going out
and exploring creative ideas for example
the surface style and the surface PC
while the surface PC isn't for everyone
it's still interesting and augments our
view of computing ever so slightly this
is a sign of progress although Apple has
innovated with a touch bar it's hard to
know how big of an impact that could
have it could be cool but to me
personally it looks like an interesting
reimagine ation of the shortcut bar
rather than a completely revolutionary
idea Apple is just appealing to those
who want to upgrade their old MacBooks
safe but not exciting
and of course if you touch an apple in
the smartphone industry the rest of the
competition is at the top of their game
right now smartphones are now more
powerful than ever before with a
competitive price especially with
efforts from the Chinese and lastly to
add to all that we've talked about we've
got the price increases the 13-inch
MacBook Pro without the touch bar went
up by 450 British pounds in the UK
supposedly because of the brexit but the
brexit technically hasn't actually
happened yet so really it could be
because there's no reason it's even
worse for the 15 inch model it went up
by 400 US dollars and a whopping 750
pounds in the UK in this global economic
climate Apple seems to be a bit out of
touch with their pricing so in
conclusion the answer is yes
Apple is starting to lose their magic it
appears that they're leaning on their
legacy and brand image to sell products
but they can't do this forever consumer
sentiment is slowly changing it's only a
matter of time before even loyal Apple
users become frustrated the
fragmentation of product lines and
disregard for consumer needs all sounds
familiar kind of like someone has warned
us about such things and the companies
forget what it means to make great
products it sort of the product
sensibility and the product genius that
brought them to those to that
monopolistic position gets rotted out by
people running these companies who have
no conception of a good product versus a
bad product and they really have no
feeling in their hearts usually about
wanting to really help the customers but
I guess in Apple's defense current
laptop and smartphone technology is
really good at the moment so it's hard
to see what the next big step is who
knows the 10th year anniversary iPhone
may be a big surprise maybe the next big
step isn't in phones or computers at all
maybe it's something like altered
reality or the Apple car or Apple's
energy generation all of which Apple is
looking at at the moment so I guess
ultimately we have to wait and see what
they do in the future and that's where I
leave the video so thanks for watching
guys tell me what you think in the
comments section below
give this video a thumbs up if you liked
it subscribe if you just stumble across
this channel this has been to gogo and
you're been watching cold fusion I'll
see you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one cold fusion
it's rethinking
[Music]
you